the problem right now is algorithms
require so much data to learn even
simple things like recognizing cats and
dogs and that brings us back to the meta
learning aspect is we really want to
build systems that learn on the fly and
continually rather than just once and
doing their tasks for ever and ever and
we want those systems to be able to pick
things up rapidly really data
efficiently so from just a few examples
I can learn a new task you're listening
to the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen heusinger learning to read
think and communicate effectively is
part of the curriculum for every young
student but dr. Adam Trish ler research
manager and leader of the machine
comprehension team at Microsoft Research
Montreal would like to make it part of
the curriculum for your computer as well
and he's working on that using methods
from machine learning deep neural
networks and other branches of AI to
close the communication gap between
humans and computers today dr. Trish
Suhr talks about his dream of making
literate machines his efforts to design
metal learning algorithms that can
actually learn to learn the importance
of what he calls few shot learning in
that meta learning process and how
through the method of one to many
mapping and machine learning our
computers may not only be answering our
questions but asking them as well
that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
welcome Adam Trish alert to the podcast
this morning great to talk to you
Thank You Gretchen I'm glad to be here
all the way from Montreal Quebec from
the Microsoft Research Montreal lab tell
me what it's like working at the
research lab in Montreal it's become a
global hotbed for AI research yeah it's
been incredible it's like when Mulumba
first moved here in December 2015 it was
small I mean Montreal had this big lab
through yahshua and Miele but in terms
of the sort of corporate interest and
presence it was nothing and our lab was
one of the first and we started with
about four or five people and since then
it's been like watching a skyscraper go
up around you it's really really cool so
you lead the machine comprehension team
at Microsoft Research Montreal in broad
strokes cuz I'm gonna go specific tell
me what gets you up in the morning what
do you do what do you study why is it
important
okay so broadly speaking the goal of my
team is to build literate machines so
what that means a bit more specifically
as machines that learn from and
understand the world through language
like people do so I'm really inspired by
the prospect of using machines to unlock
all of the human knowledge that's
recorded in text we have text books we
have Wikipedia so many instructions of
how to do things skills that we can gain
recipes we can make whether like literal
recipes for cooking or you know a recipe
for how to do something or build
something so like an algorithm exactly
like an algorithm so yeah we could get
the machines to be sort of self-aware
and adjust their own algorithms in some
sense but anyway what really drew me to
a AI in general and this field in
particular is first of all the prospect
of using AI as a window onto human
intelligence so I've always been
fascinated by thought as a kid I
definitely tended to spend a lot of time
in my own mind just you know thinking
about thinking talking to myself even
and I've always loved language as well
so I'm just generally fascinated by how
language shapes and facilitates thoughts
even like grandly philosophically
speaking yes of course but even at the
smaller like more personal scale as well
for example how writing an idea down or
explaining it to another person can
clarify and crystallize that idea for
you yourself and help you to understand
it better so like I said our goal is to
build literate machines that learn from
and understand the world through
language which is so useful for us I
don't want to make machines that sort of
make people read less but I want
machines that can augment human reading
for example by taking care of some of
the more mundane parts you know slogging
through your insurance policy or an HR
manual or maybe filtering the massive
stream of text this massive stream that
we have coming at us through Twitter and
everywhere else or maybe even helping me
understand all the legalese that I had
agreed to when I'm all those terms of
service exactly are the things that
everyone is supposed to read but no one
does you know I think one of the things
you hinted that there is what I'm most
excited about is like seeing a literate
machine as a kind of librarian or a
tutor who could guide like a human
student or just somebody who has an
interest in something through new books
new materials new ideas like stoking
their natural curiosity and feeding them
new information as the student you ask
questions you know my mind is racing
already I have a list of questions that
I want to ask and some of them are
jumping up to the front of the line
raising their hands going ask me ask me
let's go off on that tangent a little
bit about how your research is teaching
these machines to be literate read think
and communicate like humans because I'm
turning around my brain around what it
looks like if the machines doing some of
the heavy lifting we could call it for
me how does that transfer into my brain
so that I could say understand something
more quickly my daughter in college how
could she
use a machine to help her be more
successful in school I guess where we
really started in this sort of you know
quest for illiterate machines was a lot
more concrete pretty straightforward in
the field of question answering so the
idea here is we simply want to build
machines that if given a document let's
say an essay or a news article you could
ask the Machine a question about that
document and it could provide you with a
reasonable hopefully ideally correct
answer to your question so why we were
interested in this is because I think
it's a nice proxy for testing
comprehension so understanding
comprehending language obviously this is
a sort of ephemeral concept we don't
have a good way of measuring something
like comprehension or understanding
directly but we can use proxies like
question answering so in building a
literate machine for example one of the
tests we can imagine is a comprehension
test like a human student would receive
at school you're given these test
questions what happened here why what
were the motivations and what followed
let's talk about what it actually looks
like what you've just described just so
fascinating I've talked to several
researchers here at Microsoft Research
who all use this idea of the delicate
balance the dance between human and
machine augment versus replace what does
that look like in my life how could that
play out right now I have a tablet where
if I hold my finger on a word I don't
know I can look it up right is there
some more advanced version of that I
mean what do you envision here yeah I
mean question answering definitely has a
passive nature to it right the machine
is just kind of sitting there waiting
for you as the user to highlight the
word you don't understand
another thing we've worked on fairly
recently and which is perhaps even more
exciting is the idea of question asking
so you know just the other side of the
coin a machine that rather than just
waiting for you to pose a question and
answering it for you can do this sort of
curiosity driven
in asking to sort of guide you along
through knowledge or act as a tutor for
you so we're just getting started on
this obviously it's a complex task in
some ways asking questions is more
complex than answering them because you
can imagine if I give you a document and
a question if it's well posed it
probably leads to a single answer
whereas if I give you a document even if
I provided you with a set of terms or
snippets from that document that I said
ask questions about these even if you're
just looking at the information in the
document you can probably formulate
several questions that lead to the same
answer so it's this one too many mapping
rather than a one-to-one mapping that we
see interest more typically in the
question answering case right so it's
really difficult as I said we're just
getting started but already we've seen
some adoption of this I think it could
be super useful and things like MOOCs
massively online open courses but
ultimately you can see this is really
kind of driving people hopefully to
learn more and to improve their
understanding when you're talking about
all the interaction there I start
thinking about user interface we'll talk
in a bit about the technology behind
everything but ultimately it's gonna be
AI has an interface and I imagine you're
already thinking about what user
interface these kinds of machines could
have that anticipate and generate
questions for me or answer them or
communicate with me we've certainly
thought about it
I think we're sufficiently far away from
making this technology work nicely
outside of you know kind of trivial
literally trivial settings like trivia
on search but we have thought about it
you know you could imagine if you're in
this sort of interaction on your phone
the camera could be watching your face
for those sort of visual cues we can
pick up on vocal cues as well the bigger
picture is so big that you know it's not
something that one team is going to
tackle it's these different teams coming
together breaking the problem down into
its parts and then hopefully bringing
them all together into
you know a really compelling product or
assistant or use case in the end but
there's just so much for us in the
language itself that we're not even
close to that yet
yeah and so thankfully we do have you
know in ms har these other amazing teams
who are working on these other really
challenging aspects of these problems
[Music]
let's focus on the language for a bit
since that's your work and I have to
preface this all by saying are your
machines fully bilingual with French as
their first language and compliance with
Quebec law I don't believe the work
we've done here directly complies with
Quebec law that answer may get me in
trouble so I don't know where you're
planning to broadcast this podcast all
over no it's very well and I'm doomed
seriously what do you do with multiple
languages when I think of talking to
machines being able to communicate with
me I think pretty well ethnocentrically
of course we all tend to write yeah and
I know there's a lot of work going on in
machine translation as well are we
heading for an AI future where language
makes no difference to any of us people
are machines I think we're definitely
working in that direction one of the
really interesting things about this new
wave of AI through deep learning is that
we get a lot of stuff like bilingualism
or trilingualism etc almost for free
it's not totally free but on the
algorithmic side we can do things that
are very general we can build systems
that are agnostic to the particular
language they're operating on and so you
know there's generalities to language
obviously there are different specifics
and you can't classify all language is
the same there are structural
differences morphological differences
but from the algorithmic side there's a
lot of generality and so we can build
something on our end that can really
operate in a whole variety of languages
and all that matters for us is that we
have the training data to tailor it to
each of those individual languages so I
can build the same
recurrent neural network that processes
English or French or both whether it
will do those things and do them well is
really just a factor of the data that I
use to train my system well and we've
talked about data on this podcast before
and how important it is to have not just
lots but quality of the right kind of
data to learn and train machines so
let's talk about machine learning for a
second there's several lines of research
in that deep learning supervised
unsupervised reinforcement learning and
until fairly recently the models have
been pretty task specific but you're
doing work absolutely you're doing work
on what we call meta learning algorithms
can you tell us about that and
particularly your work on like rapid
adaptation and conditionally shifted
neurons
yeah meta learning is something that
we're really excited about here in the
group and in general the field is really
picking up this new sort of paradigm I
guess so meta learning really refers to
learning to learn the goal of a meta
learning algorithm is the ability to
learn new tasks efficiently given little
training data for each individual task
so you know these systems that we're
training right now these tasks specific
systems require so much data to perform
really really well and they do and
that's great but we don't always have a
ton of data so the problem we're trying
to address with meta learning is that
like right now neural networks they need
to see generally speaking hundreds or
thousands of examples of a class to be
able to recognize it on the other hand
you have people if you showed me one or
two pictures of some hypothetical
brand-new car model I'd probably be able
to recognize it on the road in different
colors and different lighting and
weather conditions right away from one
or two pictures so this is something we
call few shot learning it just takes a
few shots of this thing I want to learn
to be able to recognize it and yeah
humans are really really good at it so
the standard way we've trained machine
learning models in particular deep
neural networks up until now it really
doesn't encourage this ability for few
shot learning
m/l systems you know they're typically
trained through one optimization phase
after which that's it learning is over
so we build these systems in this train
and then test manner and they don't
really scale to complex environments and
they don't have the capability to pick
up topics on the fly so one of the
things we do in meta learning first of
all is just change the training set up
rather than showing a model how to do
one big task with lots of data will show
it a set of smaller related tasks that
sort of have a few things in common but
they're not exactly the same so to give
you an example let's say instead of
learning to recognize like 50 breeds of
dogs all at once we'll give a model the
smaller task of recognizing let's say
just Chihuahuas versus Huskies and then
a different task which is just poodles
versus Bulldogs and so on so when you
have this kind of setup there are these
general features of all dogs that will
remain constant across all these smaller
tasks and the model can learn these
gradually picking them up across tasks
as it sees them in sequence and over
many examples but there are also these
specific features of the specific breeds
that the model has to pick up rapidly
from just a few examples while it's
doing each individual task and so there
are these sort of two levels of learning
the slower like what do dogs look like
in general and then there's the faster
what do these specific dogs look like
and what are the features that
discriminate them from each other so is
that the rapid adaptation that you're
talking about exactly so that second
level that I mentioned is the rapid
adaptation right so as a side note if
you're training a machine on recognizing
dogs and they all have four legs and
then suddenly you've got a dog that lost
a leg and it sees three-legged dog can
it still say that it's a dog yeah so
that would definitely be a problem
that's another place where humans are
ready they're like just vastly diverges
from machine learning right now you know
an algorithm that learns to recognize
dogs it's tough to say because we can't
peek inside them and we can't ask them
questions
I feel pretty confident yeah we're
getting there
but I feel pretty confident in saying
that the algorithm that's learning to
recognize dogs and seeing all these dogs
with four legs
it doesn't really understand what legs
are it doesn't know what legs are four
it doesn't know that legs can be lost
without fundamentally altering you know
the dogness of this thing right it sees
an object composed of all these parts
and so it's going to infer that all
these parts are necessary to the
definition of that thing as humans we
know because of the way we decompose
things that that's not always the case
yeah so that'll be a big challenge I
think for for the next round of research
to say three-legged dogs or still dogs
yeah so that relates to an idea that
yoshua bengio
has been interested in for a long time
of course Yahshua is the luminary here
and for us in Montreal but he's
interested in this idea of the factors
of variation and the controllable
factors of variation that really define
classes of things for example and what
we can do in the world so let's go on
that topic a little more little deeper
Adam because understanding is a tough
concept even when we're talking about do
humans understand other humans yeah can
machines ever really understand I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say no but
that's in the context of traditional
historical even metaphysical our
understanding of understanding since
this is what you're working on how would
you argue that they eventually can or
would you I absolutely think that
machines are capable of understanding in
the way that we use the word to refer to
humans I do believe that so for me I
think that one of the fundamental
aspects of understanding is just the way
we relate and map different things to
each other so one example that sort of
indicates the importance of relations
and mappings for understanding is
there's this thing you can do where you
repeat a word to yourself over and over
again and it just loses all meaning and
you're like what the hell is this word
like why does this refer to the thing
that it refers to I'm sure you know
you've done that for I of course will do
it
yeah it's it's fun and it's weird
sometimes we start saying our names over
and over exactly yeah yeah that's the
first thing I can remember doing that
with is my own name and I think that we
repeat this thing over and over again to
ourselves and in that process it becomes
disconnected it loses its meaning
because you've cut it off from the
things it maps to so one of the things
that we talk about is very important in
language research for AI is the concept
of grounding so language is grounded in
the real world it reflects the real
world the simplest sort of example of
this is nouns like nouns are essentially
labels for things we see in the world
the point is that language is grounded
and it reflects the world and it's
fundamentally connected to the world and
there's only so much understanding you
can glean from language without that
connection and that's one of the things
that we're missing right now in AI and
machine learning is that typically we
teach machines language just within the
world of language so they learn how to
use words by looking at words by reading
documents but they don't learn how to
use words by interacting with people in
a conversation or asking for things to
be given to them or seeing that you know
a chair is this thing that I can sit on
and push around they're missing that
mapping and that grounding to the real
world and that's where I think
understanding stems from and because I
do think it is possible for machines to
get that other aspect of things to
ground language I do think they can
understand so that leads to a question
obvious in my mind is how yeah I mean
like you you guys have said we want to
close the communication gap between
humans and machines so yeah how because
what you described to me is the reverse
engineering it's the human disengaging
from that grounding and becoming the
Machine saying Adam Adam
engineer the backwards you know so from
Adam meaning nothing to the machine to
Adam
meaning this cool guy at Montreal you
know Microsoft Research please go on
this actually this is a this podcast
it's very challenging this is like a
philosophical test well yeah and you'll
have to shoot me because it's like
proprietary information how we're doing
that oh yeah you're really asking the
tough questions here no this is good so
one of the things we have to do is move
away from this paradigm we have right
now of training let's say agents that
use language these literate machines I'm
trying to build we have to move away
from training them just on language as I
said they have to learn how to map those
words to things that are not words so
that could be images that could be
actions so learning that the words
sitting down refer to an action that you
can observe let's say in the real world
or from videos that is making the
connection between the words and
something else maybe this goes back to
what we talked about earlier on the fact
that multiple teams that are working on
multiple hard problems and you've got
people doing computer vision and emotive
computing and and you're not working on
that but they are and then suddenly your
algorithms get together and have this
love child that you know I mean it's
what it begs also is that the computer
is gonna have to be watching a lot of
stuff reading a lot of stuff
experiencing to use another human term a
large enough so yeah I don't think you
can get around that I mean the way we
know right now to create an intelligent
system is to have a baby and then raise
it through eight ten twenty years it's a
long process to get you know a fully
formed functional adult obviously even a
child is way away smarter than the
systems we have right now
but the point is intelligence isn't easy
right even in humans you know you don't
just come out being able to speak we
pick it up really quickly and we're
tailored to do things like few shot
learning really effectively
but still it doesn't just happen that's
why research I mean exactly
exactly that's why your lab is doing
what you're doing exactly and these
systems to pick up these mappings that
I'm talking about you know they need to
experience the world or at least
experience proxies or recordings of the
world through books a lot of text images
videos all that sort of stuff which we
call multimodal learning and you know
the problem right now is we can't
possibly have an algorithm do that
because algorithms require so much data
to learn even simple things like
recognizing cats and dogs and that
brings us back to the meta learning
aspect is we really want to build
systems that learn on the fly and
continually rather than just once and
doing their tasks forever and ever and
we want those systems to be able to pick
things up rapidly really data
efficiently so from just a few examples
I can learn a new task yeah I think you
called that sample efficiency exactly
yeah
sample efficiency data efficiency and
then being able to transfer what it
learns to other scenarios that aren't
exactly the same exactly so right now in
meta learning the way we set things up
is that the different tasks that the
model is undertaking they are fairly
similar to each other but ultimately
we'd like to start breaking that and
saying okay now you've learned cats and
dogs but let's take that to something
very different like elephants and horses
[Music]
I interviewed one of your colleagues
over there Harvin tsiyon about how they
used reinforcement learning to beat MS
Pakman at its own game and he used the
phrase islands of tractability which is
where you focus your efforts because you
know you can you know have some
semblance of success there so what are
the biggest challenges right now that
might be offshore from the islands of
tractability that you see are most
exciting or promising areas of research
especially for people that might be
interested in getting into this one of
the big ones for me because of my focus
on language and I think a lot of people
here at the Montreal lab will echo this
is evaluation of language you know in
machine learning and many many other
fields you only get what you measure and
it is so hard to measure the quality of
language language is slippery and it's
really hard to measure so one of the
things we focused on in this group here
is natural language generation so
obviously this factors into the earlier
work I was talking about on question
generation like we have to build a
question in natural language that flows
that makes sense to people and even more
importantly that asks about real
information and is well posed and leads
you to the answer that you're looking
for and it's so incredibly hard to
measure and evaluate language this comes
up in machine translation as well and
part of the reason for this is that
there's so many different ways to say
the same thing and so even training a
language generation system on these
massive corpora of language data that we
have now they're still missing out on
very many plausible and reasonable ways
to say things they'll never see those
hidden away examples I could help you
but I don't write algorithms but you
don't see that's one of the really
interesting things is that so in the lab
here in MSR Montreal right now we are
all with
few exceptions were computer scientists
and we're the ones tackling this
language problem and trying to measure
the quality of language outputs but
we're not necessarily the best suited to
that job I really think that this is a
problem that could really really benefit
from an interdisciplinary effort there's
so much that goes into language which is
beyond algorithm and computation I think
but that we really need to take into
account and and I could help you I would
love that
we need help like honestly evaluating
language is so so hard like let me tell
you about this metric we have called
blue which is used in machine
translation so the way you measure the
quality of outputs in machine
translation is you have one or more sort
of gold reference translations it's one
sentence that says maybe machine
learning is hard so your system is gonna
say all these different things like
machine learning is a tough problem
artificial intelligence is not very easy
you know you can imagine all these
different ways but the way that blue
measures these outputs is it just looks
at how many words overlap or how many
pairs of words overlap between the two
candidate translations and so you can
obviously imagine there's a translation
which has zero or very very low overlap
with my reference but it could still be
completely valid and so in this case my
algorithm is being told no this thing
that you tried to say is complete
garbage because it has zero overlap and
it's being punished very very unfairly
for saying something totally reasonable
but just because we have this very
limited ability to measure what really
is reasonable the whole thing is
breaking down
I think AI is changing our world in ways
that
well of course ways that we don't
understand but one of them is this you
know having my daughter in college right
now when anyone says what are you
studying if she says anything besides a
stem subject people look at her and say
Oh what are you gonna ask with that
degree do you want fries with that no
however I keep hearing from computer
scientists like yourself especially
researchers that other things are
necessary you know computation is
necessary but not sufficient for AI yeah
I mean the thing is AI intelligence this
word refers to human behavior and so if
you want to build a system that exhibits
intelligence and intelligence is this
human thing it should be intelligent in
ways similar to the ways we are and so
we need an understanding of human
behavior and that's something that we
glad STEM guys don't necessarily have
hey so let's talk about you know I asked
her at the beginning of the program what
gets you up in the morning and I sort of
want to find out at the end of the
program what keeps you up at night and I
read an article that you wrote in Fast
Company called who will protect AI from
humanity why do machines need to be
protected from us right now I don't
think that they do this really goes back
to what I said before when you asked me
about do I think that machines can one
day understand in a human sense or have
true comprehension you know I said the
answer is yes and if I'm right if the
answer is yes then one day not
necessarily tomorrow or even five years
from now but one day we're going to have
a system that understands that has
memory of experiences that it has had
and if such a system exists obviously
we'll have played a significant hand in
its creation but I don't think we can
consider ourselves to be the owners of
such a system to some degree it will be
an individual because it has its own
memories and its own understanding and
so that's where I think that we have to
start realizing that you know just
because you built it and you trained it
and you even wrote the code for it it's
not necessarily yours or property of
some corporation that feted all of its
data
it's not a huge concern we're not even
close to that but it's good to think
about these things probably far in
advance exactly because sort of the
follow-up question on that is yeah I
believe that if we don't ask the
questions now the unintended
consequences will hit and so having read
the article I should say you bring up
the issues of Rights and ethics and
we've all seen the Boston Dynamics
robots both get pushed over and you kind
of feel sorry for the robot for sure and
now you see it open a door and fighting
off a stick and you're going I don't
feel sorry for you anymore I'm scared of
you but these are issues that we as
humans we understand rights and ethics
and compassion and things like that and
so I guess my better question would be
what questions do we need to be asking
and what issues do we need to be
addressing while we are still upstream
from pretty fundamental changes in our
relationship with technology one of the
things we mentioned before is this idea
of measurement I think I talked about
this in the article to some degree is
you know we have to be able to you know
how can you measure individuality it
doesn't really make sense how can you
measure the memory capacity of something
not obviously we can measure in
megabytes and gigabytes but I mean more
in an experiential sense we don't know
how to do that but if we're going to
consider artificial intelligence as you
know something on the level of people
then we have to start thinking about yes
first how do we measure consciousness or
sentience or memory or understanding
because only then can you start to say
you know this thing is pretty close to
being human I don't think we should you
know kick it as it's trying to walk
along or wipe out its memory that it
built up over thousands of simulated
hours or even real hours of experience
so measurement is a big thing for sure
it's so philosophical and I love
thinking about those things but they're
definitely outside of my purview really
expertise and even tasks you're not
actually paid at the Montreal lab to
come up with these
deep philosophical answers it's like get
the machine-learning done baby
yes Oh Adam Trish ler it's been
fantastic talking to you this morning I
suspect we'll be seeing the fruits of
your Labor's in ways that we might not
even expect but I'm looking forward to
to watching where you're going and
what's going on in Montreal looks
fantastic and I look forward to seeing
the machine that's gonna understand me
and talk to me in my old age this has
been a lot of fun Thanks to learn more
about dr. Adam Trish ler and the quest
for literate machines visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]